I never really doubted that I wanted to
come to MIT I mean it's actually the
only school that I applied to I really
liked the atmosphere of MIT I like being
surrounded by curious people hiding
Timothy 42 would be your control for
that experiment okay the brain and
cognitive sciences department itself was
a huge attractor for me I like that you
could participate in research as an
undergraduate through the Europe program
and I started doing that from fall
semester freshman year we have a
transgenic Huntington's disease model
fly and this fly if we express the
mutant huntingtin protein strongly
throughout the nervous system the fly is
die and so very simply we wanted to find
something that would allow the Flies to
live if we find a gene that's involved
with that pathway that could be a target
for potential new therapeutics to treat
the disease the females the abdomen and
appoint and the males instead of coming
to a tip the abdomen is rounded because
they have a sex cone the main advantage
of fruit flies is just that it's so easy
to manipulate them genetically and you
can do large-scale genetic crosses with
them very quickly because they emerge
very very quickly when we find something
interesting we take the larvae and
dissect them and then we image the
neuromuscular Junction to see whether
they still have these protein aggregates
whether the synapse itself is still
overgrown it's where they tm6 over
career just dancing I'm so Curly's in a
second Oh yep so these are so there's no
curly in here at all these are just tm6
over a wild-type I'm really lucky in
this lab because I have a good balance
of autonomy and responsibility on one
hand and mentorship on the other as a
cellular chaperone Meg for example has
been super open about teaching me new
techniques that I want to learn but she
also gives me projects that I can
nurture on my own to sort of have this
idea what it's like to have
responsibility over a project and the
gratification of getting your own result
my goal in life generally is just to
find something interesting and research
is one of the ways to achieve that but
it just happens to also be the most
fulfilling one because it's curiosity at
the service of others